[Music]
the prize are for a loved one she'll
never see again
others console her they were here in Moo
Levi killed ten years ago fleeing heavy
and indiscriminate shelling they were
forced onto a tiny patch of land with
nowhere to go
many were separated from their families
as they fled my husband went missing we
were on in different directions I ran
with my children one way my husband went
in another we didn't see each other
after that I tell my children their
father is alive and he'll come home one
day but in my heart I think he's gone I
think he died music plays as mourners
light flames for those who died the UN
says some 40,000 people were killed in
mere weeks other reports indicate the
death toll is much much higher some
survivors saw family members perish
before their eyes unable to forget what
they witnessed they're desperate to
remember a relative these girls were
orphaned here a decade ago sister
Krishan II helps care for children
without parents she says even the very
young remain traumatized they remember
they remember the path their families
took as they fled they remember being in
a place where so many died they remember
parents and the children wanted to come
here now one of the girls didn't want to
in the past thinking about her father
but wanted to be here today
the moles have come to this remembrance
event from all across the country
there's sorrow but there's also a sense
of guilt
everyone has dreams I've studied I have
a job but the people who died here had
dreams too and that's devastating I'm
living my life they lost theirs they say
it's up to them to memorialize their
dead four thumb holes in Sri Lanka the
grief is shared the pain still raw